if your appendix feels like it's
screaming at all the other organs inside
your stomach that's normal right hi my
name is Fifi no no you know it's
different now it is October that was a
sentence that almost didn't get to the
end is October the end of October is
Halloween Halloween is dress-up time for
children and adults all you have to be
creeps and pervs Halloween is a great
holiday to see people's true colors
people dress up as what you could only
assume they either think or want the
world to see them as lots of people are
youtubers / one of the youtubers these
days so I thought I'd give you some
inspiration here are five youtuber
Halloween costumes that only require
five items for each costume that's
number one first of all I couldn't be
doing more of a Halloween costume
my self care makeup fully done
sweatpants fully loaded
I didn't my pants are just on ready to
go for the first costume you're gonna
need some sort of vintage rock t-shirt
of a band you likely really do listen to
a bright red lip a sassy red wig with
bangs a martini shaker and a tiny judgey
hairless dog with its tongue always out
and wallah you are may really hard
that's number two for this costume
you're gonna need tight muscles a toy
sick tank top that's likely your own
merch a toy 7 shaggy blond-haired with a
coil it bandana a toy stick a slit
savage bird and yellow and you've become
Logan Paul costume number 3 for this
cost me a dark t-shirt shaggy brown hair
do with some sort of dark hat a camera
at all times
and a constantly strained relationship
with your friends and loved ones based
on a seemingly endless amount of fear
and lies and to bioroid david dobrik for
this one you need a crisp white polo
buttoned all the way up along
Nordic looking wig an arbitrary prom and
I'm dead behind the eyes facial
expression and some sort of irreverently
morbid philosophical question do you
think animals want to kill themselves
the way humans want to kill themselves
I look at you your papi Wow and costume
number five a generic male hoodie or
sweater a curly brown wig a pair
purposely distressed Ravens some sort of
electrically charged mode of
transportation and the seemingly
disgruntled loved one who doesn't really
want to be in the shot let's talk about
gun control tada you are Katie nice -
thank oh there are five youtuber
Halloween costume ideas let me know if
you guys choose any of them and I might
make more of this sort of video so let
me know in the comments down below which
youtuber I should make a Halloween
costume out of that sounds very Hannibal
Lecter what do you call a torturous
college class a Hannibal Lecter I'll see
myself out don't forget to subscribe to
this YouTube channel and click that
little Bell notification so you can
notified when I upload videos because
sometimes they happen and you don't get
notified and then sometimes they don't
happen and you don't get notified so may
as well get notified I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday
in theory other than that I don't know I
get way so confident this feels great I
mean did I even need the wig this is not
that I order to do this but it's not
worth it it's not worth